Негативний бік екології пов'язаний із заводами.
Хіба ми зможемо їх зупинити?
Півміста на заводах працює.
Зробити місто по-справжньому курортним. Прибрати всі ці заводи.
Якщо заводи прибрати, тут не буде роботи.
Все на заводах тримається.
Якщо хочете врятуватись, їдьте з Маріуполя і все.
Біжіть!
У Маріуполі подекуди не відразу зрозуміло, чи то заводи стоять посеред міста,
чи то навпаки - будинки побудували серед заводів.
Тут, на березі Азовського моря, розташовані два металургійні гіганти -
комбінат імені Ілліча та "Азовсталь".
Обидва підприємства входять у групу "Метінвест"
олігархів Ріната Ахметова і Вадима Новинського -
і у десятку найбільших забруднювачів атмосфери в Україні.
Комбінат імені Ілліча останній антирейтинг навіть очолив,
викинувши у повітря над Маріуполем
понад 226 тисяч тонн шкідливих речовин.
Разом з тим просто під трубами доменних печей живуть люди.
А у цій школі, що за триста метрів від забруднювача-рекордсмена,
навчаються їхні діти...
Школа - зачинена на карантин. Але поспілкуватися з нами
погодилась учителька інформатики Вікторія Пікуз.
Зустрічаємося з нею, а також з екологічним активістом,
депутатом міської ради Максимом Бородіним біля її будинку.
Вікторія живе зовсім поруч зі школою,
де вона працює і де навчається її донька.
Тож від диму їй не сховатись ані на роботі, ані вдома.
Діти ідуть в школу і всім цим дихають.
Школу варто було би перенести,
або ж якщо вона зручно розташована, хоча б модернізувати якось.
Скільки тут працюю - у мене дерев'яні вікна.
Тобто весь бруд з вулиці потрапляє прямо в школу.
Хоча б вікна поміняти, зробити систему очищення.
Це вже декілька років хочуть зробити.
Обіцяють, але нічого не робиться.
Фактично вчителі і діти знаходяться в тих же умовах,
що й робітники заводів, які за шкідливість виробництва
отримують надбавки, а ці люди - ні.
Де ж тут справедливість?
Системи очищення у школі встановлювати не поспішають -
ані підприємство-забруднювач, ані місто.
Натомість на балконі у Вікторії екоактивісти встановили пиломір -
всього таких приладів у місті декілька.
Вони дозволяють моніторити рівень забруднення онлайн -
для Вікторії це вже так само звично,
як дивитися на термометр.
Якщо показники зависокі, у Telegram мені приходить оповіщення.
Я хоча б зачиняю вікна,
не виходжу з дитиною на вулицю гуляти.
Кілька днів томУ все було червоне.
Головний біль, погане самопочуття.
У людей алергії, астма.
Щоб переїхати звідси, потрібно продати квартиру.
А квартири тут якщо хтось і купує - то за безцінь.
Я з Маріуполя не хочу переїжджати,
але хоча б в інший район…
Мені подобається місто, море,
але якби ж воно було чистим…
Щоправда, у порівнянні з 2012 роком,
сьогодні у Маріуполі дихати легше.
Тоді викиди були настільки нестерпними, що тисячі містян
вийшли на найбільший в історії України екологічний протест -
і таки змусили "Метінвест" піти на поступки.
Після протестів на комбінаті "Азовсталь",
що розташований у центрі міста,
було закрито агломераційну фабрику -
надшкідливе виробництво, на якому виготовляють
сировину для виплавки чавуну у доменних печах.
Модернізацію ж аглофабрики на комбінаті імені Ілліча
"Метінвест" обіцяє завершити до кінця року.
За даними компанії, це найбільший екологічний проєкт за всю історію України.
Серед інших проєктів - реконструкція доменних печей на "Азовсталі".
Натомість на комбінаті імені Ілліча -
забруднювачі номер один - доменне виробництво залишається застарілим,
стверджує екоактивіст Максим Бородін.
Глобально не модернізовано доменне виробництво,
розташоване за нами.
На сьогодні третя доменна піч зупинена для модернізації.
Але, на жаль, замість повноцінної модернізації
з дворівневими ливарними дворами,
наразі буде зроблена лише часткова,
а потім, з часом, нам обіцяють і повноцінну.
Але чи буде вона згодом і коли саме -
до цього є великі питання.
І є велика недовіра.
Разом з Максимом Бородіним їдемо до іншої
"гарячої екологічної точки" Маріуполя - комбінату "Азовсталь".
За допомогою квадрокоптера фільмуємо апокаліптичні картини
коксохімічного виробництва у самісінькому центрі міста.
Щодо коксохіму - моя позиція однозначна.
І позиція більшості містян, які розуміють, чим це загрожує.
Ми не зможемо зробити коксохімічне виробництво
у центрі міста екологічним.
Тому єдиний варіант, на який ми згодні,
це будівництво коксохіму за межами міста,
з урахуванням рози вітрів.
У центрі міста доісторичне виробництво
нам не потрібне.
Коксохімічне виробництво на території "Азовсталі" нам не показали.
Натомість провели екскурсію на одній із модернізованих доменних печей.
Інженер, відповідальний за екологію, каже, що працювати
після реконструкції тут стало значно безпечніше.
До того ж, модернізація дозволила вдвічі зменшити кількість викидів
від виробництва на цій печі.
До вимОги екоактивістів прибрати шкідливий коксохім
з центру міста інженер ставиться скептично.
Підприємство сьогодні будує свої плани з реконструкції,
виходячи зокрема з обсягів фінансування,
які ми можемо собі дозволити із отриманого прибутку.
Без коксу ми сьогодні не зможемо працювати,
а купити його немає де.
Побудувати новий коксохім десь в іншому місці -
це масштабний проєкт, який з огляду на поточну ситуацію
на ринку власники навряд чи зможуть собі дозволити.
За власними даними, "Метінвест" у 2019 році
витратив 137 мільйонів доларів
на покращення екології на маріупольських комбінатах.
До того ж, у компанії не втомлюються підкреслювати значення обох підприємств,
на яких працюють понад 25000 маріупольців, для економіки міста.
Представники компанії стверджують - пришвидшити модернізацію неможливо.
Щоразу, коли ми говоримо з громадськістю,
всі хочуть робити це швидше.
Влада також вимагає від нас пришвидшити наші програми,
бо ми активно йдемо до європейської спільноти
і запроваджуємо норми,
які були закладені під час підписання
угоди про асоціацію України і ЄС.
Але ж ми розраховуємо на власні кошти.
Це якась лімітована сума.
Ми не можемо просто взяти якісь мільярди і вкладати їх туди,  куди ми хочемо.
Навіть коли у Європі переходили на нові стандарти,
то уряди цих держав йшли назустріч
промисловості і виділяли якісь додаткові кошти
з того, які ми самі платимо.
Це, наприклад, екологічний податок.
Ми перераховуємо щорічно величезні суми.
Те, що поштовх модернізації на маріупольських комбінатах дали багатотисячні протести,
у компанії визнають неохоче.
Тут вважають, що екоактивісти недооцінюють зусилля підприємств
із поліпшення екологічної ситуації, проблему перебільшують, та й взагалі -
тільки й думають, як закрити комбінати-годувальники.
У свою чергу екоактивіст і депутат міської ради Максим Бородін вважає,
що власники думають передусім про свої витрати,
а довгострокову шкоду, яку виробництво завдає довкіллю,
ніхто у грошах не рахує.
Разом з тим, наголошує Бородін, про закриття комбінатів не йдеться.
Але думати про диверсифікацію економіки міста,
розвивати туризм та IT-сферу, потрібно вже нині.
Я вважаю, якщо на комбінаті Ілліча правильно модернізувати виробництво
і організувати логістику, є шанс, що завод працюватиме,
і не буде такого дискомфорту для містян.
А щодо "Азовсталі", я думаю, що є можливість,
нехай навіть із залученням державних інвестицій,
для перенесення його з цього місця, де він нині розташований.
Розібрати й зібрати завод реально.
Але для цього потрібна політична воля і стратегічне мислення.
Утім, поки що маріупольці очікують на завершення вже розпочатих
екологічних проєктів на металургійних комбінатах.
Зокрема, модернізації аглофабрики на ММК імені Ілліча.
А екоактивісти кажуть, що пильно стежитимуть
за виконанням зобов'язань підприємств.
І запевняють: у разі їхнього недотримання нові протести неминучі.